[Musica]
[Applauso]
il
tempo il tempo è un concetto relativo e
dipende molto da che punto di vista da
che prospettiva lo si considera dal
punto di vista della Scienza per esempio
e della fisica in particolare il tempo
non è che è un'illusione le leggi che
governano l'universo Infatti non fanno
distinzione fra presente e passato e
futuro ma tutte le informazioni di cui
l'universo ha bisogno per andare avanti
sono presenti sono contenute in questo
preciso istante per noi esseri umani
invece le distinzioni temporali sono
alla base del sentire quotidiano noi
impariamo dal passato viviamo il
presente e facciamo piani per il futuro
io mi occupo di scienza ma anche di
esseri umani sono uno psicologo che
studia il modo in cui il cervello Dà
vita a funzioni cognitive come la
memoria e l'apprendimento e come Dà vita
alla nostra esperienza soggettiva voi vi
chiederete cosa può dirci la psicologia
sul tempo Beh negli ultimi anni eh i
progressi nell'ambito delle neuroscienze
cognitive il mio ambito di studi hanno
portato allo sviluppo di una nuova
visione del cervello che ha a a che
vedere con il modo in cui noi ci
rapportiamo con il tempo mentre infatti
in passato si pensava che il cervello si
limitasse a reagire passivamente alle
stimolazioni esterne adesso si sa che il
cervello invece
creativamente
simula tutto il nostro presente e così
facendo proiett Ci Proietta nel futuro
queste simulazioni sono basate invece su
modelli di realtà che sono stati appresi
in passato ad esempio se noi dobbiamo
immaginare quando ogni giorno ehm
usciamo di casa per recarci al lavoro il
nostro cervello simula momento dopo
momento quello che succederà
dopo ad esempio dopo il portone di casa
comincerà a simulare il bar in cui
prendiamo il caffè e subito dopo il la
fermata dell'autobus e questo accade
senza che noi ce ne rendiamo conto il
fine è quello di ridurre al minimo le
sorprese gli eventi inaspettati per
ridurre al minimo le energie che gestire
questi eventi inaspettati richiederebbe
e ci permette di funzionare quasi con il
pilota
automatico questo funzionamento però non
è esente da Falle i modelli che il
nostro cervello crea per per simulare il
nostro cervello possono essere obsoleti
o peggio disfunzionali e il nostro
pilota automatico può non funzionare in
modo appropriato ritornando all'esempio
precedente quando noi usciamo di casa Eh
dopo il portone il nostro cervello
comincerà ad aspettarsi il bar ehm in
cui prendiamo il caffè ma può capitare
che il bar non c'è più è chiuso ad
esempio e se noi continuiamo a
funzionare con il pilota automatico
rischiamo di vagare senza direzione né
meta alla ricerca della fermata
dell'autobus quindi eh questi modelli Eh
predittivi che caratterizzano il
funzionamento del nostro cervello ci
permettono Sì di funzionare con il
minimo dispendio di energie ma D'altro
canto ci predispongono a determinati
problemi conoscere questi meccanismi
Tuttavia apre le porte a nuovi approcci
Alla sofferenza mentale anche alla
nostra vita di tutti i giorni come
illustrerò nel resto del mio intervento
nelle esempio precedente aggiornare i
nostri vecchi modelli è semplice con un
minimo sforzo ci possiamo rendere conto
che il bar dove di solito prendiamo il
caffè è chiuso e allora
possiamo realizzare ad esempio che c'è
un negozio di fiori al suo posto e
possiamo muoverci verso la fermata
dell'autobus esistono Tuttavia eh dei
casi in cui aggiornare i vecchi modelli
obsoleti o disfunzionali non è così
semplice un caso emblematico è
rappresentato dal dolore fantasma che è
un tipo di dolore cronico che si
manifesta in soggetti che hanno subito
l'amputazione di un arto ad esempio un
braccio e che lamentano un dolore
cronico proprio nella parte del
corpo che è stata amputata il cosiddetto
artto fantasma E cosa succede in questo
caso il cervello produce simula un
dolore che si riferisce al passato e non
riesce ad aggiornare are questo modello
di realtà perché il l'oggetto del dolore
il braccio ad esempio non è più presente
quindi manca un feedback un messaggio
che comunica il cervello che può
smettere di provare dolore
ora casi più comuni sono rappresentati
da disturbi come depressione e ansia nel
caso della depressione il cervello
simula un mondo arido privo di piacere
che non riesce ad aggiornarsi anche di
fronte a esperienze
positive così il soggetto con
depressione si chiude in se stesso
perché le sue azioni perdono di valore e
questa chiusura riduce drasticamente le
possibilità che il soggetto possa
incontrare in futuro esperienze positive
il mondo continua a rimanere arido
diventa ancora più arido in un circolo
vizioso nel caso dell'ansia invece il
cervello simula un mondo in cui da un
momento all'altro qualcosa di
preoccupante anche
catastrofico dovrebbe accadere questo
evento preoccupante è molto lontano
dalla realtà Quindi l'ansia che viene
generata è immotivata Ciò nonostante il
soggetto con ansia mette in atto dei
comportamenti per controllare questo
evento preoccupante oppure prevenirlo ed
è il caso eh della fuga nelle fobie
oppure del
ehm nel disturbo ossessivo compulsivo è
il caso del
rituale e quindi il soggetto con ansia
vive in un
mondo futuro preoccupante che da lì a
breve crede che succederà ma che in
realtà non si realizzerà mai esistono
forse esempi che ci toccano più da
vicino che ci riguardano tutti e che
rappresentano anche il modo in cui i
nostri i meccanismi predittivi che Sto
alla base del funzionamento del nostro
cervello possono essere dirottati e
causare sofferenza e noi trascorriamo
una grande quantità di tempo davanti ai
nostri dispositivi portatili ai nostri
smartphone quello che trovo molto
interessante è che gli studi Ci dicono
che più della metà del tempo che
trascorriamo davanti ai nostri
dispositivi lo trascorriamo scorrendo
distrattamente i social media e vi
ricorda qualcosa questo scorrere
distratto Beh io direi che è molto
simile all'esempio precedente in cui il
nostro pilota automatico non trova il
bar in cui prendiamo il caffè ed è
destinato a vagare senza direzione né
meta e forse questo è quello che
facciamo quando scorriamo i nostri
social media noi vaghiamo senza
direzione né meta per ore e ore
distaccando dal momento presente e se
abbiamo tristezza o dolore la tristezza
e dolore rimangono perché non trovano
prove che provengono dal presente che
poss possono
falsificar se abbiamo preoccupazione o
ansia rimangono o peggio aumentano
perché non ricevono messaggi
rassicuranti provenienti dal presente e
non è un caso che l'utilizzo degli
smartphone sia collegato a disturbi come
ansia e
depressione conoscere questi meccanismi
Tuttavia ci consente di identificare con
precisione dove sta il problema e anche
di pensare a metodi efficaci per
risolverlo nel caso del dolore fantasma
così come nella depressione così come
nell'ansia o nella vita di tutti i
giorni quello che conta è consentire che
il nostro cervello possa aggiornare i
suoi vecchi modelli disfunzionali sulla
base delle esperienze sensoriali che ci
provengono dal presente dal momento
attuale nel caso del dolore fantasma Ad
esempio la cura più efficace al momento
non è rappresentata da una terapia
farmacologica sofisticata ma Ma è un
semplice specchio Gli scienziati hanno
scoperto infatti che Mettendo uno
specchio di fronte all'arto intatto e
creando l'illusione così che anche
l'arto mancante sia ancora presente
riduce a lungo andare sensibilmente il
dolore quello che succede è che la
presenza dell'arto manda dei messaggi
visivi rassicuranti al cervello che Gli
permettono di aggiornare i vecchi
modelli di realtà i vecchi modelli di
dolore e e gli mandano questo messaggio
che gli comunica che può smettere di
provare dolore ora è molto affascinante
molto interessante non credete e questo
esempio ci dimostra anche che noi
possiamo utilizzare i processi i modelli
predittivi del nostro cervello a nostro
vantaggio per creare una vita più piena
e più serena un metodo efficace è
rappresentato ad esempio dalla ricerca
delle novità che sono eventi che si
discostano enormemente dal dal nostro
passato e Forzano il cervello ad
aggiornare i suoi vecchi modelli
imparare a suonare uno strumento
musicale imparare una nuova lingua
imparare un nuovo sport mettersi davanti
a situazioni sconosciute o uscire dalla
propria comfort zone d'altronde le
ricerche ci dicono che le novità hanno
sul cervello lo stesso effetto che hanno
le soddisfazioni le
gratificazioni Infatti Sebbene le prime
esperienze nell'apprendere qualcosa di
nuovo possono essere
anti i primi successi anche i primi
piccoli successi porteranno delle
gratificazioni enormi Io ad esempio ho
imparato di recente un tipo di
meditazione che si chiama
mindfulness Quanti di voi Sanno cos'è la
mindfulness siete in molti Beh la
mindfulness si è rivelata
efficace nel trattare disturbi emotivi
ma anche nel potenziare capacità
cognitive come memoria e attenzione e
alla base della della mindfulness c'è
proprio eh la possibilità di allenare la
capacità di vivere il momento presente
concentrandosi sulle sensazioni che
provengono dal corpo ma anche sui eh
sulle informazioni sensoriali le
informazioni che ci provengono dai sensi
focalizzandosi anche sui dolori sulla
tristezza e sulle preoccupazioni ma
senza permettere loro di distaccarci dal
momento presente Quindi allenarsi al
vivere nel momento presente riduce il
peso delle aspettative passate e riduce
anche il peso delle preoccupazioni
future e ci permette di destrutturare
tutti quei meccanismi che caratterizzano
la nostra routine quotidiana e anche il
nostro giro vagare senza direzione né
meta fino a non molto tempo fa Io
provavo terrore all'idea di dover
parlare in pubblico anche di fronte a
poche persone grazie alla mindfulness
adesso presentare in conferenze per me
non è più un problema e posso anche
pensare di parlare di di fronte a voi in
un evento come questo quindi utilizzare
questi piccoli accorgimenti la ricerca
delle
novità ascoltare le informazioni che ci
provengono dai sensi oppure che ci
provengono dal nostro
corpo ci permette di allenarci a vivere
il
presente che altro non è che negare al
nostro vecchio sé di prendere il
sopravvento sulla nost nostra vita di
tutti i giorni ma creare un S di volta
in volta sempre nuovo migliore e che
abbia a disposizione gli strumenti più
aggiornati per consentirci di vivere al
meglio il tempo che abbiamo a
disposizione su questo mondo
[Applauso]
Grazie
n